como una catástrofe de proporciones
históricas así describió las
inundaciones en el occidente de alemania
a mean light quien no solamente es el
líder regional de una de las zonas más
afectadas sino también el candidato con
mayor probabilidad de reemplazar a
angela merkel como canciller del país
tras las elecciones federales de
septiembre y es que las imágenes de las
inundaciones que se repiten en los
noticieros y en las redes sociales son
realmente aterradoras en las zonas más
afectadas continúan las labores de
rescate algunas de las preguntas más
urgentes que tratan de responder los
servicios de emergencias son cuántas
personas continúan desaparecidas y
cuántas personas exactamente han perdido
sus hogares y por tanto necesitan
albergue temporal mientras tanto aquí en
berlín los principales ministerios se
están poniendo de acuerdo para
desarrollar lo que ha sido escrito como
un gran paquete de ayuda un paquete de
ayuda que podría ser presentado el
próximo miércoles luego de que se reúna
aquí en berlín el gabinete del gobierno
federal bajo el liderazgo de la
canciller merkel